Okay.
Are you one of those people who hate these little crawling things or maybe these
ones with the stingers creep you out more?
Have you ever wished that all the insects would just die out?
Picnics would be much more pleasant and so what?
Gardening.
Could the world become a better place if insects disappeared or would this have
terrible consequences?
Not obvious for us at first glance,
this is what if,
and here's what would happen if all insects disappeared from the planet.
If you think bugs only exist to give you the creeps and the chew and the lettuce
in your garden,
you're wrong.
Well not totally wrong.
Some of them are in fact meant to destroy crops,
give you a skin irritations in addition to painful stings and even worse spread
diseases like Zika and malaria,
but 90% of them are not only harmless but beneficial to us and to the planet.
They say without insects,
the world would fall apart.
Just how bad would that be if we put all the insects on the planet together on a
scale,
they would weigh approximately 300 times more than all humans combined.
If you haven't set a phobia,
you probably want me to stop right here.
Just let me add that the ants alone would weigh more than all humans.
If our planet suddenly had all this weight off it's shoulders,
farmers would be the first to celebrate.
They'd no longer need to pour chemicals on their crops to save the harvest from
hungry pasts,
but that celebration wouldn't last long because without insects we'd all starve
pretty fast
and no,
we don't mean that.
Those bold adventurers who snack on crickets and grasshoppers somewhere in
Thailand would starve.
Humans might be predators in the food chain,
but insects are the ones to hold this chain together.
They are food for some reptiles,
small birds and frogs.
If all insects vanished,
those animals would cease to exist to the animal's feeding on frogs and reptiles
would be the next to die off and then the ones further up the chain.
Eventually this disruption would work its way up to humans.
Think you could survive by going Vegan wrong again.
80% of all plant life on the planet is made up of flowering plants,
meaning they require pollination to reproduce.
Insects are the ones who make this happen by physically transferring pollen from
a male anther to a female stigma.
You can argue the birds and bats,
even wind can pollinate too,
but most of the work is done by bees.
WASPS moths,
butterflies and flies.
Without them,
it's game over for most plants,
depending on what your food preferences are,
50 to 90% of your diet comes from those flowering plants.
There would be no fruit,
no vegetables,
no rice,
and no weep.
This also means no food for cows,
chickens,
most freshwater fish and all the animals we humans eat.
It doesn't matter if you're a vegetarian or a meat lover.
If the insects disappeared,
you'd have no chance of long term survival.
You'd be left to slowly starve on a planet heaped up with piles of organic
waste.
Because not only do insects feed small animals and pollinate plants,
there are also major decomposers of dead stuff from leaves to corpses.
That wouldn't be the world you'd want to live in,
and to be honest,
not all the insects are gross looking.
Wouldn't you agree?
Join us next time on what if.